the group of us who came up with the
idea to actually build our own platform
came to it out of a particular set of
experiences we had where something we
were looking for wasn't there I'm on the
board of a conservation organization
that I'm very committed to and have
worked on for many years and we went to
organize a fundraising campaign around
the event of fielding a team in the New
York Marathon we had brought a few of
these young Masai warrior guys over from
Kenya that I've known for many years and
put together a team of 30 people to run
in the marathon obviously we were doing
all the traditional things going after
corporate sponsors and looking for a few
big angel funders but we wanted to reach
out in a grassroots way so we kind of
looked around at like what was out there
in terms of the platforms that you could
communicate on over on one end of the
spectrum we saw social networking
platforms with an emphasis on the social
but not particularly well engineered
specifically to engage people in a
fundraising interaction and then on the
other end of the spectrum there were you
know donation mechanisms there were
things that were clearly you know you
could set up and get people to donate
but they had almost none of the vitality
and dynamism and personality and
creativity of social networking
platforms we looked at each other and
said we can do better than this and
pretty quickly in the course of a summer
set up our own team site we raised about
1.2 million dollars more with 30 people
then some groups had with like 300
people that was the moment that we all
kind of looked at each other and said we
could easily build this out into
something that's instead of being
specific to the event we were doing you
know we could easily just pull the
specifics out an engineer a really
robust a template that works well for
individuals works well for an
organization let's see if we can if we
can build something that fulfills this
niche
you